[Musique]
nous sommes au bord du rhin côté
allemand à breisach aujourd'hui des
français et des allemands s'y sont
réunis pour parler réchauffement
climatique et transition écologique il
d'une quinzaine de milliers d'habitants
vu d'ici
les semer internationaux sur le climat
et les rapports du giec peuvent sembler
bien longtemps pourtant ici aussi on
commence à prendre en compte l'urgence
climatique
transgreen datar ats prize à tout hasard
est une petite commune mais de mon point
de vue les communes doivent être des
exemples
surtout en ce qui concerne le
réchauffement climatique nous avons
développé un concept de préservation du
climat avec vingt mesures concrètes que
nous finançons et réalisons ce que ne
font pas d'autres communes nous
souhaitons développer de nouvelles
mobilités en réduisant la circulation
urbaine
nous allons également revoir notre plan
local d'urbanisme afin que les nouvelles
constructions ne soit plus que des
maisons à énergie positive qui pourront
réduire la consommation d'énergie
la rencontre se tient dans le cadre de
sa turbine la semaine des transitions
dans le haut rhin
objectif pour le conseil départemental
qui porte l'événement voir et imaginer
l'avenir énergétique dont le rhin
supérieur
le climat concerne la planète et que le
renard est pas la pollution
il faut que l'on travaille avec nos
voisins allemands avec nos voisins
suisses
ao question de l'avenir du climat
et d'ailleurs nous proposons à
l'ensemble de nos partenaires et à
toutes les personnes intéressées de
travailler avec nous la mise en place
d'ici deux ans d'une locale coop 21
transfrontalière à l'échelle de notre
territoire
bien sûr le pouvoir d'action des
collectivités comme le conseil
départemental est limité quand même les
états ne parviennent à se mettre
d'accord
l'alsace et ses voisins suisses et
allemands ne sauveront pas le climat à
eux seuls pourtant au travers de
rencontres comme celle ci et de projets
partent
ils entendent bien prendre leur part
c'est déjà au niveau local et j'ai même
envie de dire chez soi à la maison et
bien que par des des réflexes différent
peut-être que ce qu'on avait durant les
dernières décennies
eh bien on peut gagner quelque chose
pour que la planète ne soit pas poubelle
nous sommes dans le kaiserstuhl au lieu
de la viticulture en bade wurtemberg
de ce côté ci du rhin comme d'ailleurs
chez leurs voisins alsaciens les
viticulteurs mesure année après année
les effets du changement climatique sur
la production
le climat change le goût du vin hausse
ça a un impact sur la vigne d'abord qui
souffrent il peut y avoir des grosses
pertes sur certaines parcelles
et puis dans le goût du vin
effectivement on abat plus d'alcool donc
plus de sucre plus d'alcool ou alors une
concentration de tanins qui peut se
faire avec ce réchauffement climatique
par exemple en alsace la date de début
des vendanges avancé d'un mois ont 30
ans il n'est désormais plus rares de
commencer la récolte la fin du mois
d'août
si ces changements impacte les terroirs
il se pourrait bien qu'il change jusqu'à
la physionomie du vignoble
selon les selon les zones et
effectivement il y à des types de sols
qui sont à privilégier selon les cépages
adapter les cépages au sol
et puis essayer d'avoir une agriculture
le plus respectueuse de l'environnement
possible autre enjeu au coeur des
politiques transfrontalières la
fermeture de la centrale de fessenheim
programmée pour juin 2020 d'ailleurs cet
arrêt des questions de production
énergétique bien sûr mais aussi
d'emplois et de développement du
territoire
c'est un défi énorme parce que ça veut
dire de voir autrement le développement
économique de ce territoire et de notre
territoire haut rhinois voir alsacien et
c'est aussi un énorme enjeu de en termes
de transition énergétique en termes
d'enjeux de transition économique tout
d'abord il va falloir recréer des
emplois
l'objectif du département du haut rhin
est aujourd'hui de faire le premier
territoire uniquement alimenté en
énergie propre et donc de
de revoir vraiment la manière dont on
raisonnait jusqu'à présent depuis des
mois la jeunesse s'invite dans les
discussions sur le climat
que ce soit au travers des
manifestations ou des interventions de
great attenberg ainsi pour cette édition
de sa turbine les organisateurs ont fait
le choix de donner aux jeunes un espace
de réflexion
vingt jeunes dits français église
allemands ont pu sur un week-end complet
se concerter à proposer des solutions
par les grands axes d'ailleurs l'un des
plus important c'est la coop 21
c'est à dire une coopération avec tous
les acteurs régionaux
c'est à dire le département du haut rhin
l'allemagne la suisse aussi qui fera que
ensemble avec des entrepreneurs et des
politiques nous pourrons créer un
changement localement un autre des axes
est la création de labels locaux avec
des produits qui ont été créés ici en
alsace ou en allemagne dans le bade
wurtemberg où justement le consommateur
saura d'où ça vient comme ans a été
transportée qu'il soit un peu plus
responsables avec ce qu'il fait pour
l'heure le département du haut-rhin
avance avec ses partenaires allemands
demain réuni de la collectivité
européenne l'alsace haut-rhinois et
bas-rhinois espère passer à l'échelle de
l'ensemble du bassin rhénan pour le
traitement des questions climatiques
aujourd'hui et toutes les collectivités
quel que soit le niveau de collectivité
doit s'emparer de cette thématique
c'est une thématique forte et dont
dépend l'avenir de notre territoire mais
aussi l'avenir de la planète est donc
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que le climat
nous le traitons à l'échelle du
transfrontalier parce que c'est à c'est
la bonne échelle demain c'est la
collectivité européenne d'alsace qui
reprendra ce grand sujet parce que
l'enjeu du climat est un danger
planétaire